The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today we embark on a
new phase of our course,
signified by the
beginning of block two.
Where in block one,
after indicating what
mathematical structure
was, in our quest
to get as meaningfully as
possible into the question
of functions of
several variables,
we introduced the
study of vectors.
Vectors were important
in their own right,
so we paid some attention
to that particular topic.
And now we're at the next
plateau, where one introduces
the concept of functions.
In other words, just like
in ordinary arithmetic,
after we get through with the
arithmetic of constants, which
is what you could basically
call elementary school
arithmetic-- you work
with fixed numbers--
we then move into algebra.
And from algebra we
move into calculus.
Sooner or later, we would like
to study the calculus of vector
functions and the like.
And why not sooner?
Which is what brings
us to today's lesson.
We are going to talk about
a rather difficult mouthful,
I guess.
I call today's lecture "Vector
Functions of Scalar Variables."
And if that sounds
like a tongue twister,
let me point out that what has
happened now is the following.
When we did part
one of this course,
when we talked about functions
and function machines,
recall that both the input
and the output of our machine
were, by definition, scalars--
in other words, real numbers.
Remember, we talked
about functions
of a single real variable.
Now we have at our disposal
both vectors and scalars.
Consequently, the input can be
either a vector or a scalar,
and the output can be
either a vector or a scalar.
And this gives us an
almost endless number
of ways of combining these,
where by "almost endless,"
I mean four.
And the reason I say
"almost endless" is this.
There are only four ways.
What are the four ways?
Well, the four ways are what?
Imagine that x is a scalar.
In other words, the
input is a scalar.
Then the two
possibilities are what?
That the output is either
a scalar or a vector.
On the other hand,
the input could
have been a vector, in which
case, there would have been
two additional possibilities.
Namely, the output would be
either a scalar or a vector.
Now the reason I call these
four possibilities endless,
or nearly endless, is
the fact that by the time
we get through discussing
all four possible cases,
the course will be
essentially over.
And to give you some
hindsight as to what I mean,
remember that we had a
rather long course that
was part one of this course.
And notice that part
one of this course
was concerned only with
that one case in four
where both the
input and the output
happen to be real
numbers, scalars.
And it took us that long
to develop the subject
called what?
Real functions of a single
real variable-- input
a scalar, output a scalar.
Now the one that we've
chosen for our next block,
next combination
that we've chosen,
is where the input will
be a scalar and the output
will a vector.
And in terms of
physical examples,
this can be made
very, very meaningful.
For example, one very
common physical situation
is that when we study
force on an object-- force
is obviously a vector-- but
that the force on an object
usually varies with time.
But time happens to be a scalar.
In other words, we
might, for example,
write that the vector F is
a function of the scalar t.
And rather than talk
abstractly, let me make up
a pseudo-physical situation.
By pseudo-physical,
I mean I haven't
the vaguest notion where
this formula would come up
in real life.
And I think that after
you saw my performance
on the explanation of work
equals force times distance
and why objects don't rise
under the influence of friction
and what have you,
you believe me
when I tell you I have no feel
for these physical things.
But I say that semi-jokingly.
The main reason is that
it's irrelevant what
the physical application is.
The important point
is that each of you
will find physical
applications in your own way.
All we really need is
some generic problem
that somehow signifies what
all other problems look like.
What I'm driving
at here is, imagine
that we have a force
F, which varies
with time, written in Cartesian
coordinates as follows.
The force is e to the
minus t times i plus j.
Notice that t is a scalar.
As t varies, the scalar
e to the minus t varies.
But the scalar e to
the minus t varying
means that the vector e to
the minus t i is changing,
is varying.
In other words, notice that
e to the minus t i plus j
is a variable vector,
even though t is a scalar.
For example, when t happens
to be 0, what is the force?
When t is 0, this
would read what?
The force is e to
the minus 0 i plus j.
That's the same as saying--
since e to the minus 0
is 1-- the force,
when the time is 0,
is i plus j, which is a vector.
You see, that vector
changes as t changes,
but t happens to be a scalar.
Now here's the interesting
point or an interesting point.
I look at this expression,
and I'm tempted
to say something like this.
I say for large values of t,
F of t is approximately j.
Now how did I arrive at that?
Well what I said was,
is I said, you know,
e to the minus t gets very
close to 0 as t gets large.
As t gets large, therefore,
this component tends to 0.
This component stays constantly
j-- or the component is 1,
the vector is j.
So that as t gets large,
F of t behaves like j.
And what I'm leading up
to is that intuitively,
I am now using
the limit concept.
I'm saying to myself, what?
The limit of F of
t as t approaches
infinity et cetera is
the limit of this sum.
The limit of the sum is
the sum of the limits.
And I now take the
limit term by term.
And I sense that this limit
is 0 and that this one is 1.
Now you see, the
whole point is this.
What I would like to do is
to study vector calculus.
Meaning in this case, what?
The calculus of vector
functions of a scalar variable,
of a scalar input.
Now here's why structure was
so important in our course.
What I already know how
to do is study limits
in the case where both my input
and my output were scalars.
What I would like
to be able to do
is structurally inherit
that entire system.
Because it's a beautiful system.
I understand it well.
I have a whole bunch of
theorems in that system.
If I could only incorporate
that verbatim into vector
calculus, not only would
I have a unifying thread,
but I can save weeks of work
not having to re-derive theorems
for vectors which automatically
have to be true because
of their structure.
Now that's, again, a
difficult mouthful.
This is written up
voluminously in our notes.
It's emphasized
in the exercises,
but I thought that I would try
to show you a little bit live
what this thing really means.
Because I think that
somehow or other,
you have to hear these ideas,
rather than just read them,
to get the true feeling.
What we do, for example,
is we re-visit limits.
And we write down the
definition of limit
just as it appeared
in the scalar case.
And let's start with an
intuitive approach first,
and later on, we'll get to
the epsilon-delta approach.
We said that the limit
of f of x as x approaches
a equals L means
that f of x is near L
provided that x is "near" a.
And I've written the word
"near" in quotation marks here
to emphasize that we were using
a geometrical phrase-- well,
I guess you can't call
one word a phrase,
but a geometrical term--
to emphasize an arithmetic
concept.
Namely, to say that f of x
was near L where f of x and L
were numbers meant
quite simply that what?
The numerical value of f
of x was very nearly equal
to the numerical value of L. And
that's the same as saying what?
That the absolute value of
the difference f of x minus L
was very small.
I just mention that, OK?
Now what we would like to do
is invent a definition of limit
for a vector-valued function
of a scalar variable.
One way of doing
this is of course
to make up a completely
brand new definition that has
nothing to do with the past.
But as in every field
of human endeavor,
one likes to plan the
future and further sorties
after one has modeled the
successes of the past.
So what we do is a
very simple device
and yet very, very powerful.
We vectorize the definition that
has already served us so well.
What I mean by
that is, I go back
to the definition which I've
written here and put in vectors
in appropriate places.
For example, we're dealing
with a vector function,
so f has to have
an arrow over it.
Moreover, since f
of x is a vector,
anything that it approaches
as a limit by definition
must also be a vector.
So that means the L
must also be arrowized.
All right?
Put an arrow over the L.
On the other hand,
the x and the a
remain left alone because after
all, they are just scalars.
Remember again, x and a are
inputs of our function machine.
And in the particular
investigation
that we're making, our input
happens to be a scalar.
It's only the output
that's a vector.
So let's go back and,
just as I say, arrowize
or vectorize whatever has
to be vectorized here.
So I now have a new
definition, intuitively.
The limit of the
vector function f
of x as x approaches a is the
vector L means that the vector
f of x is near the vector L,
provided that the scalar x
is near the scalar a.
Now the point is that
the "x is near a"
doesn't need any further
interpretation because a
and x are still scalars.
The question that comes
up now is twofold.
First of all, does it make sense
to say that f of x is near L?
Does that even make sense when
you're talking about vectors?
The second thing is,
if it does make sense,
is it the meaning that
we want it to have?
Does it capture our
intuitive feeling?
Let's take the questions
in order of appearance.
First of all, what does it mean
to say that f of x-- the vector
f of x-- is near the vector L?
In fact, let's generalize that.
Given any two
vectors A and B, what
does it mean to say that the
vector A is near the vector B?
Now what my claim is, is this.
Let's draw the vectors A and
B as arrows in the plane here.
Let's assume that they start
at a common origin, which you
can always assume, of course.
To say that A is nearly equal
to B somehow means what?
That the vector A should be very
nearly equal to the vector B.
Well remember, if
two vectors start
at a common point,
the only way that they
can be equal is if
their heads coincide.
Consequently, with A and B
starting at a common point,
to say that A is
nearly equal to B
should mean that the distance
between the head of A
and the head of B
should be small.
But how do we state the
distance between the head of A
and the head of B?
Notice that that has a very
convenient numerical form.
Namely, the vector
that joins A to B
can be written as either
A minus B or B minus A,
depending on what
sense you put on this.
We don't care about the sense.
All we care about
is the magnitude.
Let's just call this length
the magnitude of A minus B.
And now we're in business.
Namely, we say, lookit.
To say that A is near B means
that A is nearly equal to B,
which in turn means that
the magnitude of A minus B--
the magnitude of the
vector-- what vector?--
the vector A minus the
vector B-- is small.
And keep in mind that
I'm now using 'small'
as I did arithmetically.
Because even though
A and B are vectors,
and so also is A minus B,
the magnitude of a vector
is a number.
Note this very important thing.
Even when I'm
dealing with vectors,
as soon as I mention magnitude,
I'm talking about a number.
In other words
then, I now define
A to be near B to mean that
the magnitude of the difference
between A and B is small.
And again, question
two-- does that
caption my intuitive feeling?
And the answer is, yes, it does.
I want A to be near B to mean
that they nearly coincide.
And that is the same as saying
that the magnitude of A minus B
is small.
At any rate, having
gone through this
from a fairly intuitive
point of view,
let's now revisit limits
more rigorously and rewrite
our limit definition in
terms of epsilons and deltas.
And by the way, I hope this
doesn't look like anything new
to you, what I'm going
to be talking about next.
It's our old definition
of limit that
was the backbone of the entire
part one of this course.
I not only hope that it
looks familiar to you,
I hope that you read this
thing almost subconsciously
as second nature by now.
But the statement is what?
The limit of f of x as x
approaches a equals L means,
given any epsilon
greater than 0,
we can find a delta
greater than 0 such
that whenever the absolute value
of x minus a is less than delta
but greater than
0, the implication
is that the absolute
value of f of x minus L
is less than epsilon.
Now if I go back to my
structural properties again,
it seems to me that what my
first approximation, at least--
for a rigorous definition to
limits of vector functions--
should be to just,
as I did before,
read through this
definition verbatim.
Don't change a thing,
but just vectorize
what has to be vectorized.
And because this definition
that I'm going to give
is so important, I
elect to rewrite it.
And what you're
going to see next
is nothing more
than a carbon copy,
so to speak, of this, only
with appropriate arrows being
put in.
Namely, I am going to give,
as my rigorous definition
of the limit of f
of x as x approaches
a equals the vector L--
it's going to mean what?
Given epsilon greater than
0, I can find delta greater
than 0 such that whenever the
absolute value of x minus a
is less than delta but greater
than 0, the implication is
that the magnitude-- see I
don't say absolute value now,
because notice, I'm not
dealing with numbers.
These are vectors-- but the
magnitude of f of x minus L
must be less than epsilon.
Now you see what I've done: I've
obtained the second definition
from the first simply by
appropriate vectorization.
What I have to make
sure of is what?
That this thing
still makes sense.
And notice that it does.
Notice that what this says,
in plain English is, what?
That if x is sufficiently
close to a-- what?
The magnitude of the difference
between these two vectors
is as small as we wish.
But we call that magnitude what?
The distance between
the two vectors.
This says what?
Correlating our formal language
with our informal language,
this simply says what?
That we can make f
of x as near to L
as we wish just by picking
x sufficiently close to a.
So now what that tells us is
that the new limit definition
makes sense, just by
mimicking the old definition.
And what do we
mean by mimicking?
We mean vectorize
the old definition,
go through it word for
word and put in vectors
in appropriate places.
Now let's see what this
means structurally.
That's the whole key to our
particular lecture today:
the structural value of this.
For example, what were
some of the building blocks
that we based calculus
of a single variable on?
Remember, derivative
was defined as a limit,
and therefore all of our
properties about derivatives
followed from limit properties.
Well, among the limit properties
that we had for part one where,
what?
Input and output were scalars.
The limit of the sum was equal
to the sum of the limits.
And the limit of a product
is equal to the product
the limits.
And remember, in
all of our proofs,
we use these particular
structural properties.
You see?
The next thing we
would like to know--
see after all, these
structural properties,
even though they're
called theorems,
essentially, they become
the rules of the game
once we've proven them.
In other words,
once we've proved
using epsilons and deltas
that this happens to be true,
notice that we never again
use the fact that these are
epsilons and deltas, that we
have epsilons and deltas when
we use this particular
result. We just write it down.
Because once we've proven
it, we can always use it.
In other words, what
I'm really saying is,
let me vectorize this.
And I'll put a question
mark now, because you see,
I don't know if this
is true for vectors.
I don't know if
the limit of a sum
is the sum of the
limits when we're
dealing with vectors
rather than with scalars.
But notice what I've done.
I have structurally plagiarized
from my original definition.
All I did was I vectorized it.
You see, what I'm
going to have to do
is to check from my
original definition
whether these properties
still hold true.
I'm going to talk
about that in a minute.
Let me just continue
on for a while.
See, similarly over
here, we talked
about the limit of
a product equaling
the product of the limits.
So again, we'd like to
use results like that.
And somebody says,
well, let's vectorize.
I want to show you
what I mean by saying
that after you vectorize,
you have to be darn careful
that you don't just go
around saying, look at it,
this is legal.
I put arrows over everything.
Sure it's legal,
but you may not have
anything that's worth keeping.
Look at this expression.
What are f and g in this case?
The way I've written it,
these happen to be vectors.
See, they're both arrowized.
Right?
They're vectors.
Have we talked about
the ordinary product
of two vector functions?
And the answer is no.
When we have two
vector functions,
we must either have
a dot or a cross
in here-- the dot product
or the cross product.
And if we're not going
to put a dot in here,
the best we can talk about
is scalar multiplication.
In other words, let me-- before
you tend to memorize this,
let me cross that out.
Because this is ambiguous.
It doesn't make sense.
And what I am saying is
that unfortunately-- not
unfortunately, but if I want
to be rigorous about this--
there happens to be three
interpretations here.
Namely, I can do what?
I can think of f(x)
as being a scalar
and g(x) as being a vector.
Or I can think of f(x) and g(x)
as both being vector functions,
but in one case
having the dot product
and in the other case,
the cross product.
In other words, to vectorize
this particular equation,
I guess what I have
to do is write down
these three possibilities.
Namely, notice in this
case, this is what?
This is a scalar multiple
of a vector function.
Granted that the scalar multiple
is a variable in this case,
this still makes sense.
Namely, for a fixed x-- for a
fixed x, f of x is a constant,
and g of x is a vector.
A constant times a
vector is a vector.
For a fixed x, f and g
here are fixed vectors.
And I can talk about the
dot product of two vectors.
And for a fixed x over
here, f of x and g of x
are again fixed vectors,
and consequently, I
can talk about
their cross product.
And the question is, will
these properties still
be true when we're dealing
with vector functions?
The answer happens to be yes.
But it's not yes automatically.
In other words, what we're
going to do in the notes is
to mimic-- to prove these
results for vectors, what we
are going to do is to
mimic every single proof
that we gave in the
scalar case, only
replacing scalars by
appropriate vectors
whenever this is
supposed to happen.
The trouble is that
certain results which
were true for scalars
may not automatically
be true for vectors.
Let me give you an example.
Somehow or other to prove
that the limit of a sum
was equal to the
sum of the limits,
we used the property
of absolute values
that said that the absolute
value of a sum was less than
or equal to the sum of
the absolute values.
And we proved that for numbers.
Suppose I now vectorize this.
See?
This now means
magnitudes, right?
And if a and b are any
vectors in the plane,
a and b no longer have to
be in the same direction--
how do we know that vector
addition has the same magnitude
property that
scalar addition has?
See, can we be sure that
this recipe is true?
Well let's go and see
what this recipe means.
By the way, this does happen to
be true in vector arithmetic.
And it happens to be known
as the triangle inequality.
And the reason for that is,
if I draw a triangle calling
two of the sides a
and b, respectively,
and the third side c, we do
know from elementary geometry
that the sum of the lengths
of two sides of a triangle
is greater than or equal to
the length of the third side
of the triangle.
What I'm driving at now is-- let
me just vectorize this and show
you something that I
think is very cute here.
If I put arrows here, this
becomes the vector a, now;
this becomes the vector b;
this becomes the vector c.
OK?
But in terms of our
definition of vector addition,
noticed that c goes from the
tail of a to the head of b.
a and b are lined up
properly for addition.
So this is the vector a plus b.
Now state the
triangle inequality
in terms of this picture.
The triangle
inequality says what?
The third side of the triangle--
well what length is this?
If the vector is a
plus b, the length
is the magnitude of a
plus b-- must be less than
or equal to the sum of the
lengths of the other two sides.
But those are just this.
And that verifies the
recipe that we want.
In other words, it's
going to turn out
that every vector property
that we need-- what
do we mean by need-- that
happened to be true for scalar
calculus-- is going to be
sufficient in vector calculus
as well.
For example, when we proved
the product rule for scalars--
not the product rule, but
the limit of a product
was the product of the
limits-- we used such things
as the absolute
value of a product
was equal to the product
of the absolute values.
Notice, for example, in
terms of case one over here,
if I vectorize b and leave
a as a scalar, the magnitude
of a times the vector b
is equal to the magnitude
of a times the magnitude of b,
just by the definition of what
we meant by a scalar multiple.
After all, a times b meant what?
You just kept the
direction of b constant,
but multiplied b by
the magnitude of a.
Meaning what?
By a, if was a positive;
minus a, if a was negative,
this is certainly true.
By the way, there is a
very important caution
that I'd like to warn you about.
And this is done in great
detail in the notes.
It's very important to point
out that when I vectorize this
in terms of a dot
and a cross product,
it is not true that the
magnitude of a dot b
is equal to the magnitude of
a times the magnitude of b.
You see, what I'm
really saying here
is, how was a dot b defined? a
dot b, by definition, was what?
It was the magnitude of a
times the magnitude of b,
times the cosine of the
angle between a and b.
Notice that if I take
magnitudes here--
I want to keep this separate,
so you can see what I'm talking
about here--
Lookit.
This factor here can
be no bigger than 1.
But in general, it's
going to be less than 1.
In other words, notice that
the magnitude of a dot b
is actually less than or equal
to the magnitude of a times
the magnitude of b.
In fact, its equality holds
only if this is a 0 degree
angle or 180 degree angle.
Because only then is the
magnitude of the cosine
equal to 1.
Similar result holds
for the cross product.
The interesting point
is-- and I'm not
going to take the
time to do it here,
because I want this lecture
to be basically an overview--
but the important point is
that you don't need equality
to prove our limit theorems.
Remember, every one
of our limit theorems
was a string of inequalities.
And actually-- and
as I say, I'm going
to do this in more
detail in the notes--
the only result that we
needed to prove theorems
even in the part one
section of our course
was the fact that the less
than or equal part be valid.
The fact that it was equal when
we were dealing with numbers
was like frosting on the cake.
We didn't need that
strong a condition.
The key overview that
I want you to get
from this present
discussion is that, when
we vectorize our
definition of limit,
that that new definition,
having the same structure
as the old-- meaning that all
the properties of magnitudes
of vectors that we
need are carried over
from absolute values of
numbers, all previous limit
theorems-- what do I mean by
"all previous limit theorems"?
I mean all the limit theorems
of part one of this course
are still valid.
And with that in mind,
I can now proceed
to differential calculus.
Namely what?
I'm going to do the
same thing again.
I write down the definition
of derivative as it
was in part one of our course.
And now what I do is I just
vectorize everything in sight,
provided it's supposed
to be vectorized.
Remember x and delta
x are scalars here.
f is the function.
I just vectorize our definition.
The first thing I
have to do is to check
to see whether the new
expression makes sense.
Notice that the numerator
of my bracketed expression
is now a vector.
The denominator is a scalar.
And a vector divided by a scalar
makes perfectly good sense.
In other words, this
can be read as what?
The scalar multiple 1 over
delta x times the vector
f of x plus delta
x minus f of x.
So this definition
makes very good sense.
It captures the meaning
of average rate of change
because you see, it's what?
It's the total change
in f over the change
in x equal to delta x.
So it's an average
rate of change.
Again, that's discussed
in more detail in the text
and in our notes,
and in the exercises.
But the point is that since
every derivative property
that we had in part
one of our course
followed from our
limit properties,
the fact that the
limit properties are
the same for vectors as
they are for scalars now
means that all derivative
formulas are still valid.
In other words, the product
rule is still going to hold.
The derivative of a
sum is still going
to be the sum of
the derivatives.
The derivative of a constant
is still going to be 0.
And keep this in mind.
It's very important.
I could re-derive every
single one of these results
from scratch as if
scalar calculus had never
been invented, just by using my
basic epsilon-delta definition.
The beauty of structure is, is
that since the structures are
alike-- you see,
since they are played
by the same rules of the game--
the theorems of vector calculus
are going to be precisely
those of scalar calculus.
And I don't have to take the
time to re-derive them all.
As I say in the notes,
I re-derive a few
just so that you can get an
idea of how this transliteration
takes place.
At any rate, let me close
today's lesson with an example.
Let's take motion in a plane.
Let's suppose we have a
particle moving along a curve C.
And that the motion
of the particle
is given in parametric form,
meaning we know both the x-
and the y-coordinates of
the particle at any time t,
as functions of t.
Notice, by the way,
that what requires
two equations in scalar form can
be written as a single vector
equation, namely, at time
t-- let's say at time t,
the particle was over here.
Notice that if we now let r
be the vector from the origin
to the position of the particle
that r is a vector, right?
Because to specify r, I not
only have to give its length,
I have to give its direction.
r is a vector which
varies with our scalar t.
All right?
So r is a vector
function of the scalar t.
Now what is the
i component of r?
Well, the i component is x.
And the j component is y.
Notice that the pair of
simultaneous parametric scalar
equations x equals x
of t, y equals y of t
can be written as the single
vector equation r of t
equals x of t i plus y of t
j, where x of t and y of t
are scalar functions of
the scalar variable t.
OK?
Now the question
comes up, wouldn't it
be nice to just take dr/dt here?
Well, I mean, that's about
as motivated as you can get.
Meaning what?
Let's see what happens.
I know how to differentiate now.
I'm going to use the fact that
the derivative of a product
of a sum is a sum
of the derivatives,
that i and j are constants.
And a constant times a
function, to differentiate that,
you skip over the constant and
differentiate the function.
x of t and y of t
are scalar functions,
and I already know how to
differentiate scalar functions.
So all I'm going to assume
now is that x of t and y of t
are differentiable scalar
functions, which means now
that instead of just talking
about motion in a plane,
I'm assuming that
the motion is smooth.
At any rate, I now
differentiate term by term.
And look what I get.
This is what?
It's dx/dt times i
plus dy/dt times j.
In other words, the dr/dt
is this particular vector.
And this particular
vector is fascinating.
Why is it fascinating?
Well, for one thing, let's
compute its magnitude.
The magnitude of any vector in
i and j components is, what?
The square root of the sum of
the squares of the components.
In this case, that's
the square root
of dx/dt squared
plus dy/dt squared.
But remember from part
one of our course,
this is exactly the magnitude
of ds/dt where s is arc length.
Remember I put the
absolute value sign in here
because we always take
the positive square root.
We're assuming
that arc length is
traversed in a given direction
at a particular time t.
But what is ds/dt?
It's the change in arc
length with respect to time.
And that's precisely what we
mean by speed along the curve.
On the other hand, if we look at
the slope of dr/dt, it's what?
It's the slope-- it's
determined by what?
You take the j component,
which is dy/dt,
divided by the i
component, which is dx/dt.
By the chain rule, we
know that that's dy/dx.
Therefore, the vector
dr/dt has its magnitude
equal to the speed
along the curve.
And its direction is
tangential to the curve.
And what better
motivation than that
to define a velocity vector?
After all, we've already done
that in elementary physics.
In elementary physics, what
was the velocity vector
defined to be?
At a given point,
it was the vector
whose direction to the
curve-- whose direction
was tangential to the
path at that point
and whose magnitude
was numerically
equal to the speed
along the curve
that the particle
had at that point.
And that's precisely
what dr/dt has.
In other words,
what we have done
is given a self-contained
mathematical derivation
as to why the derivative
of the position vector r,
with respect to time,
should physically
be called the velocity vector.
And then again, analogously
to ordinary physics,
if v is the velocity vector, we
define the acceleration vector
to be the derivative of the
velocity vector with respect
to time.
Now I was originally
going to close over here,
but my feeling is
that this seems
a little bit abstract
to you, so maybe we
should take a
couple more minutes
and do a specific problem.
Let's take the particle that
moves along the path whose
parametric equations are
y equals t cubed plus 1,
and x equals t squared.
In other words, notice that
for a given value of t-- t
is a scalar-- for
a given value of t,
I can figure out
where the particle is
at any time along the curve.
For example, when the time is
2, when t is 2, x is 4, y is 9.
So at t equals 2, the particle
is at the point 4 comma
9, et cetera.
Notice that to
understand this problem,
one does not need vectors.
But if one knows vectors, one
introduces the radius vector r.
What is the radius vector?
Its i component
is the value of x,
and its j component
is the value of y.
So the radius vector
r is t squared i
plus t cubed plus 1 j.
Now, by these results,
I can very quickly
compute both the velocity and
the acceleration of my particle
at any time.
Namely, to find the
velocity, I just
differentiate this
with respect to t.
This is going to give me what?
The derivative of
t squared is 2t.
The derivative of t cubed
plus 1 is 3 t squared.
So my velocity vector is
just 2t*i plus 3 t squared j.
Now to get the
acceleration vector,
I simply have to differentiate
the velocity vector
with respect to time.
And I get what?
2i plus 6t*j.
And I now have the
acceleration, the velocity,
and, by the way, the position
of my particle at any time t.
In particular,
since I've already
computed that the
particle is at the point
4 comma 9 when t
is 2, let's carry
through the rest of our
investigation when t is 2.
When t is 2, notice
that in vector form,
r is equal to 4i plus 9j;
v is equal to 4i plus 12j;
and a is equal to 2i plus 12j.
Pictorially-- and by the way,
to show you how to get this,
all I'm saying here is
that if we come back
here recalling that t cubed is
t squared to the 3/2 power--
this simply says that y is
equal to x to the 3/2 plus 1.
So I drew the path
in just so that you
can get an idea of what's
going on over here.
All I'm saying is
when somebody says,
where is the particle at time
t equals 2, it's at the point
4 comma 9.
And notice the
correlation again.
The point 4 comma 9 is the
point at which the vector 4i
plus 9j terminates.
Because you see, that
vector originates at (0, 0).
I can compute the velocity
vector-- namely what?
The velocity vector has its
slope equal to 3-- 12 over 4.
And its magnitude is
the square root of 4
squared plus 12 squared.
That's the square root of 160,
which is roughly 12 and a half.
I can now draw that
velocity vector to scale.
In a similar way, the slope
of the acceleration vector
at that point is 12
over 2, which is 6.
So the slope is 6.
That's a pretty steep line here.
And the magnitude is what?
The square root of 4 plus
144-- the square root
of 148, which I just
call approximately 12,
to give you a rough idea.
I can draw this
into scale as well.
In other words, in just
one short overview lesson,
notice that we have
introduced what
we mean by vector functions,
what we mean by limits.
We've inherited the entire
structure of part one.
I can now introduce
a position vector,
differentiate it
with respect to time
to find velocity
and acceleration,
and I'm in business,
being able to solve
vector problems in the
plane-- kinematics problems,
if you will.
We're going to continue on in
this vein for the remainder
of this block.
We have other coordinate
systems to talk about.
Next time, I'm
going to talk about
tangential and normal components
of vectors and the like.
But all the time, the theory
that we're talking about
is the same.
Namely, we are given
motion in a plane.
And we can now, in terms
of vector calculus,
study that motion
very, very effectively.
At any rate, until
next time, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.